rolava em todos há felizmente pressa não
vou cantar é vai falar um caminho do
trabalho que eu tenho feito ao longo
deste tempo não só em está como agora
mais recentemente em portugal e fazer
vou falar daquela que foi aquilo que a
gente nem consegue a fazer outro evento
em 2004 mais ou menos mas eu queria
falar não digo foram muito técnica por
nome dos funcionários em três anos cerca
de anita é uma grande fabricante tem uma
certa muito tempo e eu queria falar há
um caminho do que eu faço mas de uma
opção mas vossa festa era um eu estiver
sentada no público ou mesmo uma das
coisas que o mundo é isso o que ela
achou fácil
portanto nós estudamos o técnico
mais especificamente estudamos a ram
batendo de comunicação como é qualquer
um que consegue comunicar com células
adjacentes não só o céu as 800 mas
também são as normas mais de santos
no final no final a andef muito pequena
é everton eu estava você precisa sem o
porque que eu faço faço é fã e olha que
o dinheiro que todos pagam para ser
feito e eu também contribui para onde é
que isto vai o que estuda feita pelo
novo é todos nós portanto é que isto é
vantajoso o que o nosso fazer o nosso
trabalho
como é que isso funciona em prova a
população e precisamos porque que eu
faço é a mostra é uma realidade é que o
que eu gosto de fazer e paixão trabalho
porque ela é mais do que eu trabalho
é uma paixão que tem é se divertir na
justificação e isso faz podem ver são as
taxas de mortalidade europa estatísticas
da europa e portanto quer encostar e que
está sobre mim eu acho que o rio grande
te estivesse muito grato junto nunca
seria muito maior comparado com
acidentes com problemas cardiovasculares
portanto é um problema epidemiológico é
muito importante hoje em dia mas tudo
explicado - tempo fao com as outras
células primeiro eo clipe ou serviço que
são as células em nossa constituição um
saco do céu onde basicamente cada uma
destas coisas ventos muito bonitas com
um núcleo lado mãe é uma célula
temos a cada hora tem células enfrenta
sua estrutura diferente também enfrenta
no entanto tem uma coisa básica que o
núcleo konder lá dentro
todos nós temos o mesmo tipo b e todas
as nossas células que de onde você
ganhar frente mas todos acham que a
mesma deveria agora o que acontece num
carro é que deveria estar no núcleo a
quando elas bebidas as células do nosso
corpo estão em adesão à ativa quando ela
se liga o que vai acontecer é um erro
nessa divisão acontece um erro o'neal
que nós chamamos de multas aos médica o
que leva a que essa senhora em uma
capacidade muito falada antenada tatua
fica imortal e aí aparecem essas coisas
que são caducas estado é uma é um
companheiro que elas começam a
proliferar indiscriminadamente e não
morre
isso em termos muito mas eu não quero
aquilo que nós estudamos em umas coisas
que em 1983 quando se olhava pra shows
que já existam microscópicas pt precisa
microscópio olhava que 19
um sentimento tão maior central solar é
um é o espaço que outras células não só
estado ficando ociosos muito importante
libertas também para circulação
sanguínea entanto não adianta perceber
que isto era um meio de comunicação que
acho que é meu a enviar mensagens a
chance de acidentes assim como órgãos
mais destaque em todas as células do
corpo humano e libertam é esses são os
chamados às urnas é muito importante eu
vou indultá lo à sua circulação
quando nós olhamos para isso o málaga
sangue e olhar pra dentro dos seus
homens quando se olha para que o tcu
está em intenso materialmente que eu
acho que tenho esse material genético da
célula original em que isto nos ajuda a
ajudar o paciente a primeira servem com
um bem como a forma pela qual nós
conseguimos vê-los a canção mas estas
coisinhas pontos a equipe são os jogos
não são as futuras micrométricas que já
a confissão foi muito que acham não é
tem pessoas muito pequeninas que existem
na circulação sanguínea e já o canto do
mundo em grande
com impunidade só conseguiu ver com isso
ficou cobra especiais de dança é exato
como eu grito
elas existem e circulação ea execução
das células como hipnose de ter
organizado uma das formas que nós ajamos
do poder é utilizado ele estas vias
pelas quais é o que consegue comunicar
com as chamadas de centros através da
libertação do seu material genético
portanto o aço material genético que
está e se inserindo pessoas ricos enviou
na manhã no seu celular
vá em circulação e entra no chelsea que
não tem nada a ver com o que aconteceu
mas ela foi tão normal o que nós
conseguimos possuía foi crescer e ficou
junto com o céu a volta do campo células
normais conseguem transformá las
evitando quero continuar com ciro não só
porque achou que conseguiria mas também
participar da sua informação genética
muito importante também seus tubos que
isso não são nossos torcedores terão que
o troféu estão fazendo no momento em que
eles conseguem ver que chegou a viajar
nessa posição até por exemplo o mal
porque o mosquito precisa pra mim não
chegando ao mal consegue alterar essas
células e fazia com que o povo não seja
muito mais atrativo para servir na
célula cancerosa por como você pode ser
uma célula do país 3o para trás com
muita pesquisa para o filho no ramon mas
como também da china han uma semana para
esquecer no pulmão é uma coisa muito
difícil de acontecer
o que acontece aqui o que é antes ele a
shell não fazem rio sexual só mas que ao
ter uma ambiente do pulmão é um órgão
setor forma aqui depois o que aconselho
serei eu tenho uma forma mais fácil
comprar mais
primeiro como é que funciona para se
poder atuar de forma a evitar as 500 e
esses problemas dessa informação
ando ponto de vista mais prato é porque
o que nós temos que utilizar essa
informação já que eu quero estar
limitado portanto uma forma mais lógica
do pensar se ia que não tínhamos acesso
uma biópsia líquida constante para fazer
a biópsia zetuan por exemplo é uma tem é
muito invasivo razão tem que ser lá e de
cá como caminho do domicílio aos o
primeiro andar para o teu nome é que ela
só em saber que alterações genéticas
aquela george daquelas duas contagens
sabendo é o que pega o liberta estas
línguas que a informação já que
constantemente são a circulação o que
nós conseguimos
é uma forma de antever poder retirar
sete ao paciente e que dá acesso a uma
biópsia líquida que é o método não
invasivo se comparadas com o fato que
queremos chegar à sua e refinar um
caminho do seu tomou conta das ruas com
18 mortos que estão à minha cidade é
muito complicado é uma diferença enorme
com eu consegui tirar sangue a pessoa
conseguir encontrar os outros homens por
uma mãe deixa hoje o cargo e olhar para
o dna cruz está dentro e sendo
especificamente que muitos sonhos é que
ela vai ganhar contar isto é e samsung
tudo isso é um absurdo tudo porque é
regrado mais valia para a população não
é o primeiro que permite é a tensão
precoce do cargo porque num
o ideal é a nossa e é um ser iluminado
fazer um texto genérico a procura desse
dna que existe em circulação no nosso
sangue como um texto que faz a voz
quando o médico lhe diz o cavaleiro é
uma idéia surgiu com um estudo mundial
conseguiríamos a seguir em relação aos
débitos em execução que tentar perseguir
sempre vamos ver que está outra ou não o
encontraram em campo que existe um
acordo na esquerda e nós nem sequer em
novembro as técnicas de imagiologia que
hoje existem não consegue tentará tomou
11 mil m metrics santo muito muito que
eu só o que fizeres tentava é não só a
detecção precoce qo o vôo aa porque isso
quer dizer quanto nós temos não parece
conseguir não se rompa se a bacia e
começa o tratamento também se uma a uma
e errou a sala título da américa vai ter
começa o tratamento da questão é que
seis a oito meses depois o tumor que o
sonho de iniciar a meta já não é o mesmo
estou ansioso porque ninguém está forma
rápida a minha é aquele mutações vários
jogos pelas próprias por senna campeão
para poder aí ter acesso a esse gênio
processo nutrientes estão em constante
mutação
portanto isso é tão difícil tratar um
cancro porque o policiamento olham para
e comercial tratá-lo passado o meia já
não é mais uma coisa
este método do biópsia
é estranho nada com o paciente podendo
ser levada e os termos constantes acesso
aqui o tipo de material porque não tem
nada ao longo da profissão é essa
podemos retirar sacas o olhar para que
os ombros que contém aquela informação
realmente tentar perceber de que forma é
que o cantor dom
isso é importante a base que vinha por
causa da terapia do tipo de terapia que
o paciente é hoje em dia faz um
tratamento muito para a generalidade da
população é é uma realidade que nem
todos os médicos eu sou sabem que não
vai ser 100% da população que vai subir
ao terminar o tratamento
sabemos que a criança cresça muito mais
percentagem de são paulo é o primeiro
não respondem ao tratamento tem
alterações médicas que não pra mim
aquela que quer achar outra vantagem
comoção que o tratado é que o tratamento
do teto não morre por exemplo movimento
ou então não há opção de vantagem é uma
questão e assim ela perceba que está a
ser atacada pela tecnologia tudo aqui
outra vez que a maior parte das vezes o
que acontece é que a existência
portanto só nas ruas só novas mutações
que permitem a existência da droga que
inicialmente estava matar
isto é outro é uma das tantas histórias
quais ter acesso constante jackson mas
existem situação termine a promotur nos
permite ter uma imagem é toda hora que o
futebol está a mudar e ele que forma é
que nós podemos alterar a terapia para
que seja mais história complexa
e para que o documento consiga hã hã
categorias a e conseguir consigamos
fazer um eletro batalha pela massa
tumoral que é muito complicado
portanto este medicamento
eu tenho contrato assinado que mesmo o
trabalho é que nós fazemos que combina
não só isso comida também é um
conhecimento mais aqui consigo entender
porque o que é o caco libertas tudo
igual só daquelas vá o que elas fazem
no entanto ano em termos mais enviados é
vantagem da oposição prótons nosso
trabalho nós atualmente estamos a fazer
e quando falo em nós cuidados entre rita
e mérica tamanho o trabalho que estamos
a fazer é para conseguir melhorar a
qualidade de vida do paciente e
conseguir melhores tratamentos
conseguiram manter a atenção propósito
que é muito importante nesse caso por
exemplo eu posso jamais é o lugar do pai
deus que sabe se que 80 por cento dos
pacientes com cancro bancas fossem
diagnosticados muita simpatia que a
solução é 80% deus ou deveriam porque é
muito fácil que é aquilo de que ele
entrou no canto de marcos que nada é que
80% dos pacientes quando aparecem na
clínica não só já tem boca comprou o
carro é completamente absurdo de ter
sintomas como tainha no taxas em filha
alexandra e este vazamento no outro lado
tentará comemorar a correr na vida da
população quem está de certa forma a
ajudar a que o conhecimento ano sirva a
população geral e é isso o que ele
queria ver o assunto